[Music]  always a little controversial beginning  Miley Cyrus goes back to her roots and  breaks down her new single Malibu  [Music]  maile gives the meeting behind her new  single Malibu in an interview with  billboard and it's quite literal I never  stopped by the shore under the Sun with  my feet in the sand that you brought me  and I'm happy that you did I'm from  Nashville stand up like I never really  went to the beach that was nothing that  was ever an important part of my life or  part of my culture elsewhere on a press  tour it was a blast from the past at  Radio Disney where they showed Miley the  audition tape that started it all for  Hannah Montana we have to put a label  you know knowing you Olivia  no but it's gonna happen and you are  just the one that's gonna do check out  et online.com for more throwbacks with  Miley like this one I'm not afraid of  nothing  [Music]